hat unsere erde einen zweiten mond ganze
100 jahre blieb unbemerkt erst 2016 nach
dem wissenschaftler die überraschende
entdeckung des aktuellen nahm 2016 h 0 3
gemacht seine umlaufbahn ist wirklich
besonders eigentlich kreis darum
gewonnen ist aber jetzt in eine
umlaufbahn um die erde eingeschränkt wie
kann das sein kann er der erde
gefährlich werden jetzt bei klick zum
tanzen herzlich willkommen
da kreist ein asteroid ein jahrhundert
um unsere erde und niemand merkt es erst
am 27 april vergessen 16 richten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
vom institut für anatomie den aktiven
2016 h 0 3 vom panzer sowie teleskop aus
das erste mal eine überraschung für die
forscherinnen und forscher den 2016 h 0
3 umkreist die erde wohl schon seit 100
jahren und blieb bisher unentdeckt
vielen dank an alle für den vorschlag
und das ist der steckbrief
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
schätzen sein durchmesser auf größer als
40 und kleiner als 100 meter ist ein
gesteins kommen wie viele tausend andere
auch in solche systeme aber eben
eingeschwenkt in eine umlaufbahn um die
erde eigentlich greift der aktuellen
genau wie wir einmal im jahr um die
sonne und zwar in einer elliptischen
bahn spektakulär an seiner entdeckung
sind zwei dinge zum einen eine
inzwischen stabile umlaufbahn um die
erde berechnungen zeigen dass 2016 haben
und sei sogar schon seit 100 jahren mit
unserer erde in verbindung steht dass
wir ihn jetzt erst entdeckt haben zeigt
wie wenig wir darüber wissen was um
unsere erde geschieht und vielleicht
auch welche gefahren im weltall lauern
ohne dass wir sie bemerken seine
umlaufbahn um die sonne herum wird
übrigens nur von der schwerkraft der
erde beeinflusst im gegensatz zum mond
ist 2016 an nur drei also nicht im
schwerkraftfeld der erde gefangen und
zum anderen sowohl der akzent als auch
der mond umkreisen die erde jedoch ist
der mond darin deutlich schneller er
umrundet und bei weitem nicht so schief
und in weniger elliptischer frauen die
anziehungskraft der erde entscheidet
also derzeit darüber dass ich 2016 an
nur drei nicht allzu weit von uns
entfernt und in unserem ort gefangen ist
berechnungen zufolge kommt der aktuell
höchsten 14 millionen kilometern und
heran
zudem lässt in die anziehungskraft der
erde aber auch nicht weiter als 40
millionen kilometer weg von der erde
noch mal der vergleich zu unserem mond
2016 halber 3 ist mit dieser entfernung
38 bis 100 mal weiter weg von der erde
als er und so fliegt er der erde mal
voraus mal fliegt er uns hinterher mal
ist er somit weiter von der sonne
entfernt
als die erde mal ist er näher an ihr
dran immer bleibt er dabei im
schwerefeld der erde
dieses wechselspiel erinnert selbst
astronomen und astronomen an ein
tänzchen zwischen zwei menschen
der erschleichung unserer erde zieht
sich nie weit entfernt und zusammen mit
der erde um die sonne wandert bezeichnen
ihn nasa wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen als quasi satellit
der aktie zwar das recht und hannes reis
übrigens nicht der erste athlet der in
seiner umlaufbahn so auffällig an die
erde gebunden ist auch der etwa 20 meter
große aktuelle 2003 in einer sieben
wagte vor etwa zehn jahren schon einmal
ein fenster mit der erde aber wenn er
noch zwei guten weg den handel drei sind
echte zweite ehrt monde als was sie
manchmal bezeichnet werden denn wie
gesagt weise sind anders als unser
echter mond nicht dauerhaft an unsere
erde gebunden und so weit waren auch im
jahr 2006 keine überraschung dass die
anziehung von 2013 an einer 72 erde
nicht mehr ausreichte und der tanz
zwischen ihm und der erde abdruck
beendet war
denn sobald die anziehungskraft der erde
übertrumpft wird von einem anderen
planeten mit größere anziehungskraft
werden uns aktuellen wieprecht in halo 3
oder damals 2013 107 entrissen und
verschwinden in den tiefen des alls
höchstwahrscheinlich wird so auch das
schicksal von 2016 h 0 3 aussehen und
spätestens dann wird auch dieser tanz
der erde mit einem absolut wohl beendet
sein bis die erde dann einen neuen quasi
satelliten dazu gewinnt nämlich dann
wenn ein weiterer erdnahe aktuell nicht
einfach an der erde vorbeifliegt sondern
seine bahn durch die erdanziehung so
verändert dass er eine art korkenzieher
bahn um unseren planeten einschlagen
wird die nasa-wissenschaftler
wissenschaftlerin sagen übrigens voraus
dass der abschied der erde zumindest vom
mini ab 2013 in einer sieben kein
abschied für immer war später 10 16
jahren wird er der erde wieder so nahe
kommen dass er dann wieder eine zeit
lang mit und tanzen wird das kind jetzt
alles putzig und lustig doch solche
asteroiden können auch eine gefahr
darstelle nach einschätzung der
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
wird 2016 handel 3ds zwar sehr
wahrscheinlich nicht gefährlich werden
auch wenn die astronomen und astronomen
in der kabine
hacker haben unter anderem auch die
identifikation gefährliche aktionen
ambitionen haben eine sprecherin der
nasa brose planetare verteidigung ist
sich sicher dass 2016 hahn und rain den
nächsten 200 jahren nicht auf die erde
prallen wird doch für die zukunft will
das niemand ausschließen dass wagen sich
die astronomen und astronomen welt mit
den besten teleskope der welt nicht wenn
es mehr infos über erdnahe asteroiden
gibt und gefahren die von ihnen ausgehen
dann erfahre was natürlich hier wenn er
dazu keine verpassen wollt dann drückt
mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den auf die glaube hier geht es
weiter mit aktuellen bedrohen die erde
zum ersten date
das ist schon etwas beunruhigend
draufklicken wenn es euch interessiert
und ansonsten bis dann gleich parat